معنا اليوم ، فلنتحدث عن
الأبقار الأولى لأنك الرئيس التنفيذي
لكاوست ولديك مبادرة كبيرة
في مشروع البحر الأحمر
وتحديدا حماية
النظم البيئية للشعاب المرجانية كيف يساهم ذلك
في المبادرة السعودية الخضراء
أعتقد ذلك  يساهم كثيرًا في ما هي
المبادرة الخضراء السعودية ، صحيح أنها
قيادة ولي العهد ، فهي ترسل
رسالة إلى العالم مفادها أن المملكة العربية السعودية
على الرغم من أنها أكبر
منتج للنفط في العالم هي من أجل
الاستدامة والأخضر في
المستقبل على المدى الطويل ، فماذا؟  هل
يعني ذلك أنه يجب عليك إنتاج
الطاقة بتجديد من مصادر متجددة
عليك الحفاظ على
البيئة الطبيعية ، فالبحر الأحمر هو
في الحقيقة أحدها ، والباقي هو الكنز
الطبيعي للمملكة الذي تريد التأكد من أن
الشعاب المرجانية محفوظة و  لست مبيضًا ،
فأنت تريد التأكد من أن الصحراء
لن تنمو وعليك أن تعرف
كيف
تزرع الغطاء النباتي
دون استنفاد المياه العذبة ، فكيف
تفعل ذلك؟  أنت تستفيد من الطاقة الشمسية وطاقة الرياح ،
لذا فإن كل هذا يتطلب فهم
الطبيعة والعلم وهذا ما تدور
حوله الأبقار ، لذا فنحن نساهم في المبادرة الخضراء
بشيء آخر مثل مشروع جيجا
بعدة طرق لذلك نحن نقوم
بالبحث
لذلك
عليك أن تفهم
اللافتات وإلا فلن تكون قادرًا
على حل المشكلة والتخطيط
للمستقبل ، فهذه
مسؤولية على الإطلاق ، لذلك نحن بحاجة إلى تثقيف
الشباب وخاصة الشباب
السعودي وسأصل إلى
الشباب والشباب السعوديين في غضون دقيقة.  أريد
أن أتحدث من قبل عن نوع
الشركاء المطلوبين لبدء مشروع كبير
كهذا
ولإحيائه فعليًا ، لذلك
نحن نتشارك مع كل من محليًا على
المستوى الوطني في المملكة العربية السعودية
وعالميًا ، والسبب الذي يجعلنا بحاجة إلى الشراكة هو
لأننا  إنه مكان صغير جدًا
لدينا أقل من 200 أستاذ ، حسنًا ،
لدينا 1600 طالب
و 100 طالب ونحن جامعة على حق ،
نحن لسنا قطاعًا خاصًا ، لسنا حكوميين ، لذا
نحتاج إلى
المشاركة  r مع الحكومات والقطاع الخاص أيضًا ،
نشارك على سبيل المثال في المملكة ، نحن
شركاء مع الوزارات وخاصة
وزارة البيئة والمياه
والزراعة في ميوا لأننا
نقوم بالبيئة والمياه
والزراعة والطاقة ، لذلك نحن نتشارك مع
وزارة الطاقة وكذلك
نتشارك  مع uh the giga project
neo
كثيرًا لدينا مشروع كبير نقوم
ببناء حديقة مرجانية كبيرة في
إحدى الجزر تسمى sousa in neo ،
شاركنا في مشروع
resty الذي كان John Picano على اللوحة ، لذلك
وقعنا مذكرة  قبل بضعة أشهر في الرياض
، سنضع بعضًا من أبحاثنا
هناك وسيقومون بدمجنا نوعًا ما في
مركز زوار يقومون ببنائه
وعالمي ، اسمحوا لي أن أذكر أن
المملكة العربية السعودية في العام الماضي كانت الدولة المضيفة لمجموعة
العشرين ، لذا خرج اثنان منها  المبادرات
الأولى عبارة عن اقتصاد دائري للكربون
سمعتم عنه الوزير قال هذا الصباح إننا
نشارك كثيرًا في ذلك من خلال
القوة الذهنية الفكرية وراء بعض
المؤشرات الأساسية لذلك  t أيضًا
الحفاظ على الشعاب المرجانية واستعادتها ، نعم ، لذلك
في الواقع ، حددت الأبقار الآن
المقر الرئيسي العالمي
الذي تعرفه لمجموعة العشرين ولكن انتقل إلى العالم
ليأتي الناس ويتقدمون
للحصول على تمويل للقيام ببعض هذه
الأبحاث ، فهؤلاء هم بعض
الشركاء وما هو  دور
الشباب السعودي
في كل هذه المشاريع الكبيرة ، هل
يساهمون في
الشباب السعودي والتعليم
والبحث وتنفيذ
هذه الاستراتيجيات أود أن أقول بشكل خاص
للشباب السعودي ،
إنه مستقبلهم
والبحر الأحمر
هو كنز وطني
لكم.  أعلم
أننا أناس لا يبني
جيلي هذا لجيلنا إنه
للجيل القادم والجيل القادم ،
لذا من غير الشباب السعودي
الذين يهتمون أكثر بهذا المستقبل يجب
أن يفعلوا ذلك
باستثناء طلاب سعوديين
تعرفهم في قبولنا  صف حوالي
نصف الطلاب السعوديين الذين تعرفهم عند
قدومهم ،
ولدينا أيضًا برامج لتدريب
طلاب المدارس الثانوية
من المملكة العربية السعودية ، حيث سيقضون
الصيف هنا في مختبرنا ،
نقوم بتمويل بعض من أفضل خريجي المدارس
الثانوية من المملكة العربية السعودية للدراسة
في الولايات المتحدة والعديد منهم يعودون
ويدرسون لذلك لدينا العديد من البرامج مثل
هذه لدينا حاضنات الشركات الناشئة ، لذا إذا
كنت كذلك  مهما كان عمرك
على حق ، فأنت صغير في الاعتبار
، حسنًا وتبدأ شركتك ، على
سبيل المثال ، تعد الاستدامة مصدرًا رائعًا
لريادة الأعمال ، فنحن نساعدهم ،
لذا غدًا في قمة الشباب أه الخضراء ،
نعم سنكون هناك
اجعل طالبًا يجري مقابلة مع امتيازه في وزير الطاقة على سبيل المثال أحد طلاب الدكتوراه لدينا الذي
سيجري مقابلة لطيفة للغاية ،
نتطلع إلى رؤية ذلك وشكرًا
جزيلاً السيد السيد توني على وقتك ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك